هي اللمسه الاخيره على يد الجوهره السوداء
ليه رحل محاطا بعائلته داخل مستشفى
باولو بينما يقول له محبه في الخارج ستبقى
خالدا ايها الملك
اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه مستذكرا
امجادا صنعها رياضي القرن العشرين الوحيد
الذي فاز بكاس العالم 3 مرات ولا يستطيع
اخفاء تاثره برحيله وهو الذي عاصر امجاده
منذ بدايته مع نادي سانتوس
فقط عشاقه من مشجع فريق سانتوس بل حتى من
خصومه
هو ملك كره القدم شخص لا مثيل له ولن ياتي
مثله ان يرحل لا هي خساره كبيره لنا جميعا
اعلان المستشفى خبر وفاته بعد صراع مع مرض
سرطان القولون عن عمر 82 عاما اثر تفاعلا
محليا ودوليا وسعيا الرئيسان البرازيليان
المنتخب والمنتهيه ولايته صارعا للتعزيه
ونشر ذكرياتهما معا كمنعه سياسيون
ورياضيون حول العالم اجمعوا على ان موته
خساره لا تعوض في هذا المستشفى
ختمت حياه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
بيليه لكن تاريخه سيبقى محفورا في عقول
ووجداني ملايين البرازيليين والمحبه حول
العالم ومن هنا سيعود جثمان النجم الراحلي
الى ربوع مدينته سانتوس حيث اعدت مراسم
وداعن تليق بمقامه
ارضيه ملعب نادي سانتوس التي لطالم شهدت
على ابداعات صاحب اكبر عدد اهداف في
العالم باتت مجهزه لاستقبال جثمانه هذه
المره فمعه انتهى مشواره الكروي ومنه
يودعه عشاقه الى مثواه الاخير سكان
الاحياء الشعبيه المحيطه بملعب ذكرياته
وامثالهم يعتبرون انهم خسروا افضل من
مثلهم بعد ان خرج من بيت فقير ليصنعه شعبا
باكمله تقوم على المساواه والامل
قوته موته
الم شديد نشعر به لخساره هذا الرجل
لاستثنائي
كنا نريد قضاء راس السنه لكن الخبر المنا
فاتينا نحييه امام ملعبه
وكان الوان شعار ناديه التاريخي اختيارات
اليوم الحداد هذا الذي اعلن في عموم
البرازيل وبات يوم الفراق قريبا
انا اول من وصل عندما تبدا جنازه الملك
فيصل الاول في الطابور اعلم انه سيصل من
سانتوس الى سو باولو وسانتظره هنا قبل
يومين تتجهز المدينه باكملها على مختلف
المستويات لوداع موهبه استثنائيه في جنازه
تعقب تنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد
ويحضرها عشاقه لاخر مره حسن مسعود الجزيره
سانتوس